en el vídeo anterior demostramos la
fórmula para la suma de ángulos en el
seno así que se imaginarán que en este
vídeo lo que quiero hacer es demostrar
la fórmula de suma de ángulos para el
coser que el coseno de x massieu es
igual al coseno de x por el coche no
deje menos si tenemos un más aquí
tenemos un menos acá menos seno de x por
seno de iu y voy a usar una técnica
bastante similar que como demostré la
fórmula para el centro los invito a que
pausa en el vídeo ya sea ahora o en
cualquier momento en el que ustedes
consideren que pueden encontrar la
respuesta por su cuenta y así como lo
razonamos para el seno veamos cuál es el
coste no de x más en este diagrama x que
es este ángulo de acá y si vemos al
triángulo rectángulo
el co seno de x más recordamos que el
coche no es el adyacente entre la
hipotenusa y aquí el lado adyacente es
el segmento a efe entre la hipotenusa
pero aquí la hipotenusa es una así que a
efe entre 1 va a ser igual a efe así que
el coseno de x más es la longitud de
este segmento a efe que estoy señalando
aquí de hecho vamos a copiar esto para
ponerlo aquí como etiqueta y que nos
acordemos que esto es el coseno de x más
ya la longitud del segmento a efe es el
coseno de x más vemos cómo podemos
encontrar esto la forma en que voy a
pensar en ello es que viendo los
triángulos rectángulos que tenemos si
podemos encontrar esto que es a efe que
déjenme escribirlo de otra manera esto
es igual a la longitud del segmento ave
la longitud del segmento ave que es todo
este segmento de aquí abajo
- la longitud del segmento efe - este
segmento que estoy resaltando acá menos
la longitud del segmento fbi y así como
vemos que luce nuestra fórmula podríamos
adivinar a que va a ser igual a b ya que
va a ser igual
efe si podemos demostrar que ave es
igual al coseno de x por el coste no
deje y si podemos probar que el segmento
f b es igual al seno de x menos el seno
de ella pues entonces habremos hecho la
demostración que queremos que el coste
no de x más bien que es igual a avn -
efe o que es igual a esto menos esto
pensemos en que son exactamente estas
cosas que es ave pues vamos a ver el
triángulo rectángulo a se ve del vídeo
anterior sabemos que el triángulo que
está arriba adc la hipotenusa de ese
triángulo es 1 y la hipotenusa del
triángulo de aquí abajo es coseno de x
así que va a ser ave
bueno pues ave es adyacente a nuestro
ángulo y o también podemos decir y de
hecho lo voy a escribir aquí abajo
podemos decir que el coche no deje estar
acá es igual a su lado adyacente que es
el segmento ave entre la hipotenusa que
es coseno de x multiplicamos ambos lados
por coseno dx y nos queda que el
segmento ab es igual al coseno de x
por el coseno de ayer que es exactamente
lo que queríamos demostrar aquí hemos
probado que el segmento ave es igual al
coseno de x por el coseno de gec todo
esto es igual al coseno de x por el
coseno de jett y ahora lo que nos falta
es demostrar que el segmento f b es
igual al seno de x por el seno de jett
bueno este segmento se ve un poquito
extraño acá pues no es parte de algún
triángulo rectángulo tal cual pero lo
que sí sabemos es que esto es parte de
un rectángulo y este rectángulo lo
usamos para la demostración de la suma
de ángulos para el seno y también la
vamos a usar ahora pues cuando esto
podemos afirmar que el segmento f b es
igual al segmento s miden lo mismo y
aquí que es ese pues ya tenemos aquí
nuestro ángulo y aquí arriba y este lado
del segmento ese es el lado opuesto al
ángulo
el segmento s el seno de iu es la
longitud de el lado opuesto el segmento
s entre la hipotenusa que es seno de x y
esto ya lo teníamos del vídeo anterior
de este triángulo rojo grande ese es el
opuesto aquí está la hipotenusa que mide
1 por lo tanto el opuesto es igual al
seno de x y aquí multiplicamos ambos
lados por el seno de x y nos queda lo
que estábamos buscando el segmento s
es igual al seno de x por el seno de iu
y nuevamente el segmento s tiene la
misma longitud que el segmento f
así que acabamos de mostrar que el
segmento f b es igual al seno de x por
el seno de ella que justamente esto de
aquí es igual a esta parte de las
fórmulas nuevamente el coche no de x más
bien que es igual a la longitud del
segmento a efe es igual al segmento ave
esté grandote menos el segmento fbi y
acabamos de demostrar que la longitud de
ave es igual al coseno de x por el
cocina de james y que el segmento fbi es
el seno de x por el seno de g y con esto
terminamos